the afghan capital is blanketed in black
and white the taliban flag flies on
every street and around each corner
taliban checkpoints and patrols
keep a close eye on their newly
conquered country
stopping searching and
hunting for enemies of the new islamic
emirate
and so for three months muhammad ishmael
and his family hid i'm becoming scared
right now
last summer as the taliban advanced
across afghanistan ishmael his wife and
eight-year-old son fled their home in
kandahar leaving everything behind
except for a couple of bags containing
their most prized possessions these
folders full of photographs from
ishmael's time with the canadian armed
forces for six years he was in charge of
security at canada's military base in
kandahar the canadians nicknamed ishmael
captain smiley why captain smiley
captain smallie like all the thai are
smiling and they call me like
smiling and yeah
in the camera why why were you smiling
all the time and that's be like
i'm a happy guy
and like all the time happy but while
ishmael was all smiles his was serious
work besides monitoring security on the
base
he also led the canadians on patrols
outside the wire
they came under taliban attack many
times once ishmael's vehicle was hit by
a taliban bomb he survived but his older
brother abdul kahir was killed on patrol
these guys were performing these
services at tremendous personal risk to
themselves canadian randy scott worked
alongside ishmael in kandahar and the
two became close they conducted patrols
and delivered food and blankets to the
local population randy is a great person
he's a great guy he was instrumental in
helping to
keep everything secure
and safe around the base
where
all of the canadians operated out of and
he and his security force out there were
directly in in the in the front line of
potential risks they saved our bacon
on more than one occasion ten years
later scott and the other vets would
have a chance to return the favor
as the taliban advanced last summer
ishmael's family received approval to
move to canada as refugees he was told
to leave his home in kandahar and make
the 10-hour drive to kabul where the
canadian government was sending a rescue
flight but they arrived at the airport
to this
thousands of desperate afghans standing
between ishmael and his escape
he recorded this video outside the
airport standing for hours waist deep in
sewage water crying out to the canadian
soldiers inside the gates for help money
time i call them hey hey i'm a captain
smiley i have my visa
but they never look at it that side what
can i say
i
i i appealing very bad
like i thinking
before of that i work with canadian
forces
i really enjoy this time why not doing
it nothing for us i feel very bad in
that time i feel very bad ishmael
planned to return to the airport with
his family to try again the next day but
that morning he received a message from
some canadian veterans warning about a
possible terrorist attack against the
airport so ishmael stayed away and was
grateful he did
[Music]
within hours isis-k suicide bombers and
gunmen attacked the crowds outside the
airport killing dozens of civilians and
13 u.s troops
and that that was right where you were
standing the day before yes that was
standing the day before the same spot i
standing there like i'll be there i'll
be die
after the attack international flights
were effectively frozen so ishmael and
his family hid at this safe house which
was urgently organized by canadian
veterans groups part of a secret network
of apartments and hotels housing
hundreds of afghans who'd supported
canada's military mission now afraid to
go outside terrified the taliban would
find them
as the weeks rolled by randy scott was
in constant contact from his home near
vancouver just being in touch to
understand what his circumstances were
to try and keep his spirits buoyed
i know he was terribly concerned
for his wife and his son it was very
tense a
very scary time at one point taliban
officials visited the safe house seen
here on surveillance video entering the
lobby they spoke to the hotel manager
but didn't check the rooms where
ishmael's family was hiding with his
photographs of the canadian military my
windows is close with the road i look at
it all night all night i never sleep
after three months in hiding ishmael's
family saw a chance to escape
a canadian ngo called the veterans
transition network hired a team to drive
some of the afghans with canadian visas
out of the country to pakistan a
treacherous trek through the mountains
and passed more than a dozen taliban
checkpoints
ishmael and his family sat in the back
seat and held their breath as their car
was stopped by the taliban
there is a money checkpoint like i
becoming very nervous finally after six
hours they arrived at the border and
crossed into pakistan
he contacted me as soon as he got into
islamabad
and he knew that his wife and his son
were safe
and we uh
we we talked uh on a video and uh well
we cried together
out of relief
that uh he and his family were safe
okay
is it working
muhammad
assalam alaikum see you
sir
good to see you i'm very happy to see
you
[Laughter]
i talked to him in a video call
like my i feel
very good like i tried to hug him in
and that's like that's be very
and
i'm very happy
after their long journey across the
border ishmael and his family checked
into this hotel in the pakistani capital
joined by dozens of others who also
supported canada's military campaign
including interpreters cooks mechanics
and their families
[Music]
most spend a few weeks in islamabad
before finally booking their ticket for
a new life in canada
captain smiley was living up to his name
i i really enjoy it i'm very happy
i'm really happy
but as he heads to the airport in
islamabad to catch a flight to toronto
ishmael's heart is heavy his mind on
those left behind in afghanistan what
does it feel like to leave
your home
in the hands of the taliban very bad
what do you think
it's so hard like
that's so hard for each person 20 years
20 years each person hard worker
they build them that country some guys
be coming they destroy for five minutes
like that
[Music]
muhammad ishmael fled his home in
kandahar with one of his most prized
possessions
this book given to him in 2011 as a gift
from canadian soldiers they signed their
names with messages of thanks
inside stunning photographs of canada
ishmael had long imagined what it would
be like to step into these pages to
leave everything behind and start a new
chapter in canada
now that dream is suddenly within sight
i'm coming down from the hotel
like i thinking i'm in a dream
ishmael his wife pahima and their
eight-year-old sonny matt just completed
their two-week quarantine
emerging from their toronto airport
hotel for some fresh air and breathing
easier after escaping taliban controlled
afghanistan
for many years i was afraid the taliban
would come and kill my husband pahima
says now i wake up feeling happy knowing
my family is in a safe country
[Music]
for six years ishmael aka captain smiley
lived and worked alongside canadian
troops like warrant officer joe lavoy we
protected them they protected us but
they protected us more so right lavoy
remembers first meeting ishmael in 2010.
they bonded on the base while playing
with the toy lavoy's remote control car
which provided much needed respite from
long dangerous days on patrol guys like
smiley like they provided us a safe
haven and kind of directed us where to
go just just to keep just just like for
myself like to bring all my guys home
how are you
we met ishmael and his son outside their
hotel and offered to take them for a
tour of their new home city is there
anything you want to do anything you
want to see
just like i want to see in the city that
the area has to be good for us
before escaping to canada ishmael and
his family had never left afghanistan
never seen a skyscraper a streetcar or
even a squirrel
yeah it's really green canada yeah and
soon it'll be very white
yeah very white yeah
i see
city a tall building yeah very tall
buildings yeah
that one's the tallest
this is canadian music
is anyone afraid of heights because it's
very high
okay ready
one two three canada
canada is a very beautiful country it's
very safe emats says i don't hear
gunshots anymore
after reaching new heights we went
looking for a taste of home kandahar
kebab are you hungry
familiar food taste is good though this
was his son's first time eating it with
a fork
that was good good work
followed by their first subway ride
their first hockey game
their first time navigating a traffic
light
even their first winter touch
in canada i really enjoy it now
in canada and toronto
it's it's good city good place
very clean green
and everything is awesome
awesome and overwhelming almost
everything here is foreign unfamiliar
and ishmael can't read english he only
learned to speak a little during his
time with the canadian military yeah
he's very different and that's been hard
like um i don't know
there is a dentist right here there is a
school right there
i don't know nothing
the family will receive some support
finding a home and a school the
government gave them each 50 upon
arrival which is all the money they have
and their housing costs will be covered
through a loan for one year after that
they're on their own
wahadat wish knows the feeling at that
time when i arrived there was no one to
help me the former interpreter moved to
toronto with his family in 2011.
i cannot
tell you how much happy i was but that
initial high was followed by a long low
for eight years he struggled to find
steady work so did the other refugees he
met most of whom moved back to
afghanistan i was lost i went to
depression i was sitting all day home i
took a lot of pills medication
i faced a lot of problems
a lot of troubles a lot of problems
but a couple of years ago wish got a
full-time job and his situation improved
thanks in part to support from an old
friend
back
[Music]
good to see you after a long time sir
both wish and ishmael worked alongside
canadian randy scott in kandahar they
connected over zoom near his home in
abbotsford and reminisced like the time
scott dressed up as santa claus to bring
a little christmas cheer to the base
red hat
some of the local guys was asking what
way what happened to this person what
happened
at sunny closets
like people are not familiar with santa
claus scott is part of a network of
volunteers supporting afghan refugees
within days of ishmael arriving in
toronto scott connected him with wish
who offered to help becoming very happy
like what what can i say and
and
yeah i can
hug each other for me
yeah
and that that's as good as a hug for me
right now
yeah
yes
grateful to be reunited in canada but
their conversation quickly turns to
those still trapped in afghanistan
there's so many friends that have been
left behind there
yes
of course so many left behind there's
like our day i thinking about those
peoples
hundreds of afghans who supported the
canadian military hid for months in
these safe houses in kabul some waiting
for approval to go to canada others
already approved but with no safe route
out of the country
earlier this month most of the safe
houses closed due to lack of funding and
the afghans were kicked out onto the
street
from canada government my
request
to please help to those people they left
behind the canadian government promised
to accept 40 000 afghan refugees so far
fewer than 4 000 have arrived in canada
but i think the canadian government
could be doing a whole lot more than
what is being done we owe them a great
deal and scott says that debt extends to
those like ishmael who've made it here
to canada but still need help and
there's services and there's some
funding available and things like that
but it takes
a community
to help welcome them
and to help them to become established
and to get back up on their feet as it
were
ishmael's canadian community now
includes wish veterans like scott
and joe lavoy
lavoy was reunited with his old friend
at this veteran-run coffee shop south of
toronto along with fellow ex-soldier
sergeant dave ward even their remote
control toy car made an appearance we
were thinking oh yes
you want to hold on a little bit
a little bit better shape when it was
over there believe it or not the men
shared a coffee
and plenty of memories from their time
together it was truly an honor working
with your teams those memories come
flourishing back and captain smiley
coming and just just just reigniting
those memories just makes me just makes
me happy as anything
super emotional
i'm not crying on national tv
ishmael's family are now waiting to be
assigned an apartment and to start
english classes pahima grew up under the
taliban's first rule in the 90s when
women were robbed of their education
she's illiterate now planning to go to
school for the first time
i am 100 happy to be here in canada i
want to learn english and make a safe
home for my family she says hockey puck
okay you want to try yeah
ishmael isn't sure what he'll do for
work but his son wants to be a pilot his
first time on a plane was the one that
brought him here to canada government
data shows first generation refugees
typically struggle but their children
are much more likely to thrive
and for that reason ishmael says there's
no looking back i hope myself and my
family and stay here and
just be like
starting new life
i try my best
how can i
do good thing in this country